Consider the case where you have way more data, way more work than processors.
In this case, your implementation speed is limited by the number of processors
because your processors are busy all the time.
So you'd prefer the implementation that is more work efficient.
Firstly, let's say you have more processors than work.
In this case, you have plenty of processors, so you're limited instead by the number of steps in the algorithm,
and you'd be willing to do more work to get fewer steps.
You've got more than enough processors to handle the extra work,
so you'd pick the implementation that is more step efficient.
There are a number of interesting parallel algorithms that have a pattern that looks like this.
You start off with a lot of work. You narrow down to not very much work.
And then, you widen back out to a lot of work.
An example of this is the Blelloch scan that we just looked at.
You start reducing with a large number of items.
You get down to a small number of items.
And then during down-sweep, you widen out to a large number of items again.
In this case, an advanced but good strategy is to start off
with a work efficient algorithm when there's lots of work.
Once you get down to not very much work, you switch to a step efficient algorithm,
when you have more processors than work.
And then, as you start to widen back out, you switch back to a work efficient algorithm,
when you have enough work to fill the machine again.
So now, as a quiz, we're going to look at 3 different scenarios of things
that we want to scan and given a particular hardware configuration.
Your task is to figure out which best suited--the serial algorithm,
the step efficient Hillis and Steele algorithm,
or the work efficient Blelloch algorithm.
And the scenarios are, you have a 512 element vector
and a machine like a GPU that has 512 processors,
you have a 1 million element input vector in 512 processors,
or a 128K element vector with one processor.